everybody
is starting at zero everybody so you're
watching this and you've got that
business idea that you've been thinking
about forever but you haven't done it
you're watching this and there's that
qualification that certification that
degree you've been thinking of going
after
but you're not doing it you're watching
this and there's that person you've had
a crush on forever but you don't think
that they would ever date you you know
the one you know that person where you
put your profile on private on Instagram
so that you can stalk them and they
don't see that you're watching all their
stories you know yourself
you know who you are you're watching
this and you're wondering if you're good
enough the company you work at has got a
job posted and there's a promotion and
you think you can do that job but you
just don't know if you're good enough I
came to tell you two things the first
thing I want to tell you is when it
comes to pursuing New Opportunities
everybody starts at the same week
everybody make sure you're the most
prepared the second thing I want to tell
you is when the noise is ringing in your
head about how you don't belong in that
room the only way to quieten that noise
is to focus on the things you do control
and the things you can do so for the
entrepreneurs right now who are
wondering if your business is going to
improve focus on the next proposal
you're sending out focus on the next
client or whom you're in a sales call
with focus on the next presentation you
have to prepare focus on the next
candidate you're trying to hire focus on
next because you don't have to know
where the lift goes you just have to
know
that if you take one step up the
stairway sooner or later you're going to
end up exactly where the lift heads up
all the way at the top hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because in my first business I quit on
my business partner I was making 300
bucks a month and I didn't have the
motivation to keep going and the thing
that got me through was studying the
stories of entrepreneurs who've had
massive success and I hope that in
sharing these stories with you you find
a motivation to keep going and if I'm
being honest I still need the source for
myself today too so today let's learn
from some of the bad and watch the 60
most eye-opening minutes of your life
enjoy
rule number two set new habits with Mel
Robbins the reason why habits are so
important everybody is because based on
uh research this is from a study that
was published a couple years ago that 40
of your behavior are what we call Habits
habits
that's just another word for patterns
okay and so I'm going to give you some
examples
of habits that you might not even think
about are a habit okay
and a pattern or a habit is simply
a behavior pattern we call them a loop
and I'm going to explain why
it's a behavior pattern
that is stored in the subconscious part
of the brain you'll also often hear
people talk about the basal ganglia and
the reason why you have habits is
because your brain loves shortcuts see
everything that your brain is doing and
your nervous system is doing we've
talked a lot about this in other
trainings but everything that your brain
and your nervous system is doing it
requires fuel just like your car
requires fuel for you to be able to go
from where you are right now to the
grocery store that's how it runs your
brain requires fuel
and your brain has figured out ways to
maximize
the fuel and to be more efficient and
the way that your brain is more
efficient is it learns habits and
patterns
and when you have a habit or a pattern
that you have memorized because you've
repeated it so many times it takes less
fuel for your brain to reflexively do
that pattern than doing something new
and I'll give you an example
um this is something you can test out
later today or tomorrow
I want you to think about like a place
that you often bike or drive to maybe
it's a grocery store maybe it's work
maybe it's school maybe it's friends
house
tomorrow I want you to consciously drive
an entirely new and different and longer
way and you will notice something you
will notice that your brain fights you
you will notice that your brain is
annoyed and you will notice that it
takes more effort for you to think about
where you're headed
because the way that you commute to work
or school or the grocery store you have
repeated that so many times it is now a
pattern or a habit Loop stored in your
brain that's why often you get to places
you always drive and you're like oh my
God who drove the car because you don't
remember driving the car because your
brain was in the background making
decisions that have already been
automated so the reason why that happens
just in summary is because if you had to
use your prefrontal cortex and focus on
every aspect and every decision from how
you pick up the toothbrush to how you
hold a pencil to all that stuff you
literally would need to take a SL you'd
need to take a nap by one o'clock in the
afternoon you wouldn't be able to
process that much new information
and so it's a way for your brain to take
a break it learns patterns automates
behaviors so let me give you some
examples of some habits you might not
think about
picture yourself
sitting at the wheel of a car
and you put the car in Reverse which
shoulder do you look over as you're
backing up
it's always the same one isn't it and
depending upon where you live in the
world it's one side of the other
it's always the same you don't even
think about it do you
that right there is a habit
that is a reflexive action and pattern
that you do without even thinking
now think about your evening routine do
you lock the door every night
at home do you have a pattern or habit
of things that you just go through in
your house for flight you don't even
think about it right
you're not like oh it's time to lock the
door about where is the door I can't
remember how to do I better Fortune no
you just get up you walk to click the
lock and it's just a pattern that you do
that is triggered by the end of the
night
here's the second thing I want you to
know about patterns
patterns repeat
patterns repeat
if you don't
interrupt a pattern and replace it with
something else the pattern will repeat
forever
so learning new behaviors and learning
new habits
is a lot more
about spotting the things that you don't
want to do anymore
and interrupting them
and then replacing those old patterns
with new patterns
and I believe that when you start to
feel broken or stuck in your life
you're not broken you have a pattern
from your past that makes you feel
broken based on where you want to go now
and I also believe that when you feel
stuck in life you're not actually stuck
you're just stuck repeating these old
patterns and until you catch them
and you interrupt them which is where
the five second rule comes in there's
nothing more powerful to help you
interrupt an old pattern than counting
backwards five four three two one to
interrupt the loop but then you have to
replace it with something else
because if you don't replace the pattern
what's rule number one about patterns
patterns repeat
so you can't just break a habit
technically you don't break a habit
technically you replace it with
something else rule number three be in
control with Gary vaynerchuk Gary I'm
asking this with love and you know for
me this was a big thing I I think it was
like
I think I've been making content for two
years before I introduced my community
to my wife yes and everyone was like Jay
you're married like people had no idea
because I just didn't talk about that
because we just got married we've been
together for a few years before that I
was like I need to be careful about of
course what we're going to say where
this is going how this feels you've
recently been more open about your
relationship yes we don't have to go
there this is you're being very kind and
I appreciate it because I respect you
I am incredibly private as you know and
the world knows because I'm going
through a transition in my life I felt
like it got to a place where it was not
sustainable for me to be 100 private and
so I've been a little more public it is
something that I'm desperately not
interested in even the part we just
talked about with my kids like it's not
somewhere I want to go yeah I don't want
to go I don't want to talk about my kids
yeah I don't want to talk about my
personal reasons no no I want you to
keep this okay and I'll tell you why I
want to remind people you're in control
yeah it's incredibly important and
appropriate and I appreciate especially
being very cordial for people to ask and
things of that nature but I want to
remind people they're in control yeah I
want to provide value and put out things
in my professional career I'm incredibly
private and feel that the world is
entitled to what you give it
so when I watch people get upset when
people get into their business I'm like
you're giving them your business by the
way you're leveraging your business
I don't want to leverage nor give my
personal life to the world
I don't think that's the right way yeah
by the way yeah I just think it's my way
yeah
um so the reason I have a little bit to
what you're referring to is it became
not sustainable because it's been a long
time and like I was in a Transit like it
just it was the appropriate time yeah
and I needed to just get some context
out there but I'm uh it's not where I'm
gonna go yeah and that's what I was more
interested by to me it's not listen us
being together my brain goes into
maximize the value at the highest levels
because we have the opportunity to for
as many people are listening the
takeaway there from my perspective is
you're in control yeah you have a
learning disability and you want to
share it Mazel Tov you don't great yeah
it took me back to something less
serious it took me 15 years of public
life to say I'm not candorous and it's
hurt me in my personal life
and it's hurt me in my business life
you get to share what you want to share
yeah and and I think people should be
careful of what they share yes you share
your abs as a like a like you're a good
shape dude people are going to talk
about your body for the rest of your
life yeah
yeah but you did that you're gonna show
your kid all the time they're gonna talk
about that relationship they're gonna
talk you're giving the world permission
yeah I prefer not to give the world
permission because that's a sacred place
for me yeah you know even look at my mom
she like the greatest gift I could give
to the world is my mom to the world the
greatest she's Alpha me
she's more experienced she's a different
perspective as a mom is that she doesn't
want it the end right I thought my dad
and mom would be reverse my dad I never
thought would love the Limelight so much
um but you know so I think if you're
listening right now please
if you're not going on social media
because you have a skeleton in your
closet
you have a disease you have a bad you
know situation you uh you're like me and
like grew up in a family where like
personal life is private that's I think
you know in Russia that was like people
would go to jail if anybody knew
anything about you so I think it
ingrained in my parents which then
ingrained in me and my sister and
brother like we're private that way
um you know I think you have to
understand you're in control Facebook
and Tick Tock and podcasts and YouTube
don't make you do anything yeah they
don't make you do anything I'm so glad
you addressed that because I think
there's and this is why I brought it up
I think there's been a mask of false
vulnerability that's been encouraged
because of social media so people think
that the more vulnerable or more open
Shore that shows authenticity yeah I
love you for that you're going to a very
smart place I would argue I see more
lack of authenticity in the way that
people are leveraging their family and
personal life because they know it does
well I think the lack of accountability
is leading to so much unhappiness
like life is so much better when you're
like this was my fault yeah absolutely
control yeah and so like you know this
was like a wrap up to control you're in
control you you decide what you consume
you decide what you believe you decide
who you surround yourself with you
decide what you put out take on
accountability yeah everybody wants to
blame right now the algorithm they're
acting as the algorithms are like
hypnosis and I understand endorphin hits
and all that but like you can delete the
app you can
like where's accountability in this yeah
right yeah absolutely no we have the
alcohol we have tobacco we have drugs we
have weapons and we have all sorts of
issues but most people play Within
moderation that's on you yeah and it's a
tough truth right it's a tough it's a
tough it's a tough truth especially when
you're unhappy also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet design
specifically for this video absolutely
for free there's a link in the
description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number four put yourself first with
Kendall Jenner how did you find the
courage to do that at the 23 Mark as
you're saying you're in a competitive
industry as you said it was overworking
it's fast paced I'm guessing there's
comparison in that industry there's
competition in that industry it's not an
easy space to be you're of course you
know you're in the top 0.01 in your
industry so it's it's hard
and the reason I asked this is because I
work with so many people in this space
and to have the courage to say no I know
that if I sort this out then all of this
is going to be just fine that actually
takes more courage than we recognize we
realize that when you have nothing then
there's nothing to lose you can actually
have a lot of Courage right but when you
have everything and there's everything
to lose and a lot of the time at least
what I've heard in in town is you know
older managers and agents and I'm not
saying you have any of this but people
that I know will be told well hey if you
don't do this like you'll be forgotten
next year or you know your career is
only going to last another six months
how did you have that courage to say no
no I need to do this like where did that
come from and I think that it's interest
like I've never thought about it that
way to be completely honest with you I
just knew that if I had gone any further
that I was going to lose myself I was at
that very I was on the teeter-totter
edge of that point where had I gone any
further I was probably not going to be
great it was so important to me to feel
good that I just knew that it was
something that I had to do and I can't
say like
you're absolutely right like there were
so many people around me that had told
me not to say no and told or told me
yeah told me not to say no told me not
to stop I fought my way out of it a
little bit because there were people
that had worked for me that you know
didn't
want me to stop because it might have
benefited them of course
um but I got to that point I just knew I
had to do it and I just I don't know I
don't know how to explain it I guess
yeah it was just such an unbelievable
Sensation that I had where I knew that
if I do this I'm gonna be better for
everyone and I'm gonna be better for
myself which means I'm going to be
better for the people around me and I
have to do this and so it wasn't really
I want to be able to live
with happiness God forbid any of this
ever went away and I think that that was
a big moment for me of being like I'm
gonna be okay if I don't get this job
tomorrow and I'm gonna be okay if I
don't get that job in a month if I have
to take this time to do whatever things
will come everything's going to work out
the way it's supposed to and I had to
trust that yeah well to me on from the
outside and it's it's beautiful that you
didn't see it in yourself figured out
and always makes it even more wonderful
but the idea that to me from the outset
that's a lot of Courage yeah I think it
takes a lot of Courage it takes a lot of
vulnerability and openness and and it
takes courage at every level whether
someone's thinking about quitting their
job to do something they love or whether
someone's trying to relocate their
family and doesn't know how or whether
Someone Like You is feeling success but
then going well wait a minute and I
think in the past few years we've seen
athletes and musicians and actors and
people in all creative Industries step
back and say well I need to put me first
yeah and I think that that's empowering
because I think we hear about burnout in
what was it that you started to do with
that Newfound time at that time like
where was is that where the Curious was
the Curiosity always there and now you
could actually follow it it was it was
it was always there and I had had a lot
of people coming to me telling me about
meditation and how it changed their life
and therapy and so many different things
and I was a bit overwhelmed because I
was like oh my God what if this is gonna
suit me I think it's a very personal
experience I think everybody has a very
different version of all of that stuff
and so it was a little overwhelming so I
think I really just took the time to be
off for a second it was even the little
things it was like being able to go to
my friend's birthday party which I
wouldn't have been able to go to before
because I was working a lot I I love
hearing that because I think it is those
simple things like
you know giving yourself that space yeah
whatever it is that you needed to do
yeah when you needed it and and like you
said sometimes it's like that's when all
the Subscribe buttons come up in front
of you and it's like try this and try
this and it's like well no no let me
just take my time it was also now that I
think about it yeah 23 I'm 26. I've had
my horse for so around that time is when
I bought the horse that I have now who
is my like I I jump her and I like how I
have two other horses but they're like
retired so I don't really ride them the
same way I ride her so yeah I guess it
was around that time too that I was like
I'm gonna do this because I love this
and like I want to get back into it and
this is what I've loved my whole life so
so it was around that time that I feel
like all of that started happening and I
bought my horse and I like started
taking more time for things that made me
really happy rule number five believe
with Eric Thomas I know you do a lot of
work with at-risk youth you go into the
prison system is part of why you do that
helping people find purple purpose and
having that spark a belief that somebody
else believes in them yeah but a part of
that is
filling this old pastor and I owe all
the people that sort of helped me to get
from where I was to where I am now and I
owe them that tough love you know and I
owe it to them to believe in themselves
and to
see that like I owed to myself to
recreate that moment between me and him
with as many people as I can as often as
I can because he said to me listen to me
there's absolutely nothing you can do
for me but pay it forward and at that
time I don't know I don't know what paid
for it was I didn't see the movie at the
time you know but afterwards I began to
understand what he meant and so I
literally wake up every day believing
that I owe the people who didn't owe me
anything
now again I I don't know this to be a
fact but I do believe that there are
people who believe that I have value
because of where I am you're talking
about people who at my lowest point that
believed in me in the way somebody today
would believe in me based on what I do
when I hadn't done anything and so I'm
like wow that's rare people don't
necessarily do that and I just felt I'm
obligated to do that to as many people
as I possibly can and that's what I wake
up like I wake up every day with this
all right I'm gonna win a Nobel Prize
and it's not about the Nobel Prize it's
not about Norway it is about
if LeBron and Michael Jordan are playing
for the finals and uh Gretzky is playing
for the Stanley Cup and somebody else is
playing for the penny like my my pennant
is the Nobel Prize because you don't get
that without helping millions of people
get from one place in their lives you
know to another I want to talk about
this idea of getting people to believe
in themselves the fact that somebody
could look at you and one thing that I
find interesting and I don't know what
you think about this I imagine that
meeting you at 16 you'd see that glimmer
of like whoa this person can be
something but at the same time there's
probably a little bit of like let me
like blow on December and just see what
happens even if I don't know that it's
going to turn into a raging Inferno I
want to give them a little bit of oxygen
absolutely what is that when you try to
give somebody oxygen what do you say to
them is it just you could do it or no
you know I think for me
and as a speaker I try to start with
like where are you so if you're in
poverty it's like okay I gotta show you
wealth like in your own world I've got
to show you
that this ideology that you're holding
on to is probably not yours you know I
tell people all the time when I grew up
you know no it was no College why didn't
I want to go to college I was in Detroit
in Detroit you could make 25 an hour
working for Ford GM or crisis so so when
you were a kid growing up in Detroit
like the gold the Apex is I got a job at
Ford Motor Company I mean I've got
salary I've got uh uh Insurance I've got
health benefits 401k like I've got a
career and so for you you growing up in
Detroit you see for it the bigger
buildings are GM you see Chrysler
Iacocca like you see him on magazines
and books and he's he's on the New York
Times bestsellers list and it's like
whoa GM Chrysler and so what I do is I I
figure out where you are and I dare you
to come out of where you are to if
nobody ever influence you where would
you want to be like what what do you
want what do you want to do not what
they want you to do if you could dream
if like what would your best life look
like for you if you didn't have to
impress your mom or your dad if you
didn't have to go to college because
your parents went to college like what
would you really do and there if they
can tell me which most people can some
people are so dark that they don't even
know what light would look like but more
often than not a kid would tell me NBA I
said no I don't let's be okay the NBA is
over where you live where do you live
are you married do you have children
what do you and if I can figure out
where you want to go at that point where
I can snatch your current reality and
help you to build a new reality to help
you to get where you go now I tell this
to people all the time
I just wanted a career I never I never
even heard the word billionaire before I
never heard anybody say the word I never
I was never I didn't even know what that
meant and one day I was in the room with
Dan Gilbert and Warren Buffett damn
and I was like whoa God why am I here
like I'm not a billionaire like I'm not
like what would I be in this like what
did they call me for why why did they
invite me into this room
and I started doing my homework who else
is in the picture went back I thought I
was um you know a detective and I'm
trying to figure out okay who else is in
the room why are they in the room what's
their net worth and then one day it hit
me
you're in the room
because you're going to be this one day
so everything you heard you didn't hear
it
just to hear it just a bit like you
heard it because you can do real estate
like Venture Capital you can't do that
these are all humans in this room so for
me I was taken into a reality
that I didn't know exist and Jamal says
it best your level of exposure often
determines your level of success so I
was exposed to billionaires so what I
try to get kids to do is say look I want
to expose you you could go to La without
going to L.A you put the you could put
the things on and go to La you can you
can go on the computer you can read a
book like you can get to Sunset without
ever going and then once you get to
Sunset here and get your sunset here you
can get to Sunset here so for me it's I
got to get in here and I gotta get in
here and if you let me into these two
spaces I can get you wherever you're
trying to get to okay keep getting the
chills
they're so powerful rule number six find
your passion with Jay Shetty one of the
questions I get asked a lot probably the
thing I get asked more than anything is
how to find your passion and to me
hearing you talk about Dharma and
identifying your essence
it really aligns with that idea
um can you explain like what is the
definition of Dharma is it different
than finding your passion is it like
what is one's true Essence when those
things are Stripped Away like how do you
begin to to approach that as a a person
or a monk quite frankly so yeah the word
Dharma means a lot of things and it's
always hard to translate ancient
Sanskrit words into modern day English
but the closest two definitions are your
true nature and your Eternal purpose so
it's almost like this is something
that's already existing it's already
almost part of your DNA and part of your
makeup and it's allowing that to be
completely Unleashed but I break it down
in the book to make it really simple
because just like you the amount of
people that say to me Jay what's my
passion what's my purpose so I use
Dharma to be described as the word
purpose
and then I create this formula or this
mathematical equation for how to unlock
purpose and to make it simple and
obviously people can dive into the book
and do the questions and everything else
that's in there it's passion
plus strengths
plus compassion equals purpose
and I'm going to say that again because
I love to break it down because I'm
going to break each of these down for
you as well that passion plus strengths
plus compassion equals purpose or Dharma
and this is also similar with the
concept of ikigai in the Japanese
terminology which is reason for being so
you find these in a lot of ancient
Traditions but now let's focus on the
word passion
how do you know what your passion is so
to break it down I've been thinking that
purpose is like an adult
passion is like a teenager
interest is like a child
and curiosity is the womb
so the birthplace of passion is actually
curiosity and interest and I think we
waste so much time trying to be like
what am I really passionate about what
do I really believe in
that's going to take years to figure out
and I've heard you say this too that's
going to take experimenting it's going
to take testing
but the thing you can start with right
now is the simplest form of what am I
curious about what am I interested in
let me take a course on that or let me
take a seminar on that or let me go and
try that or let me shadow someone who's
done that and that experimenting process
is the only way to unlock your passion
so to me that's step one
the other way of approaching your
passion is through compassion
so actually a lot of people find their
passion through pain they find it
through pain that they went through
pain of someone that they loved and lost
pain of someone who went through a
physical ailment in their life or
something that they went through and
then that becomes their passion that
they've seen the worst horrific type of
pain and they never want to see it again
and that becomes what illuminates their
passion to them and so compassion is
another way and actually sometimes a
simpler way because we all know what
pain we don't want to feel again and we
all know what pain we don't want someone
else to feel again why do you think so
many people struggle with this and why
do they struggle so much to find the
answer for themselves
I think we care so much because deep
inside of us we know
that meaningful work has a reward
and I think we know that because we know
that meaning less work has no reward and
I think everyone at some point in their
life has done some form of meaningless
work whether that was you tapping away
on the buttons in a corporate company
whether that was you doing paperwork and
filing an admin for that office job you
did one summer or whether you were
flipping burgers and doing you know
frying fries or whatever it was like
everyone's done something that didn't
satisfy them and by the way all of those
things I've just said could be really
satisfying to someone else and that's
the crazy thing about passion that it's
not linked to a particular activity for
everyone it could be completely
different there's a great study from the
Yale School of Management that I talk
about in the book and amyever's new skin
her team tried to find work that they
thought would be considered challenging
and they found that they looked at
hospital cleaners and Hospital workers
because they thought that might be some
of the challenging and sometimes the the
filthy work that people may have to do
can you imagine like cleaning up after
people pass away or cleaning up after
they just
like urinate or whatever it may be
they're cleaning bed sheets they're
cleaning toilets
and so they asked some of the people
that worked in these hospitals to Define
their job
most of them as expected said
meaningless insignificant low-skilled
and basically they read their personnel
manual
the interesting thing is they asked the
same question to people different people
doing the same job
but this time the answer was different
these different people doing the same
job said that they did highly skilled
work it was highly fulfilling and they
saw themselves as healers they saw
themselves as carers and they saw
themselves as transformative in the
healing process of their patients
because they saw themselves in
connection to someone actually
recovering and being better and rule
number seven the last one before some
very special bonus Clips is have faith
with Ed bylet you bring up your love for
the Lord can you um I know this is
personal you haven't shared much about
this
um publicly but can you share a little
about your faith Journey
sure that was the hardest chapter in the
book to write I told you this because I
didn't want to offend anybody or put
anyone off who has a different Faith
because I admire and respect people of
all faiths and I don't like when I
believe religion becomes judgmental or
hey I know something you don't know or
I'm right and you're wrong we're talking
about faith here right so it's something
that I really can't stand and I I by the
way I'm a Christian I also think
sometimes I have this feeling that
sometimes organized religion or friend
Irwin likes to say organize religion
sometimes gets in the way between people
and Jesus so they have all these
thoughts about that stuff but for me
there's one conclusion that you know
although my Earthly father was a
incredible man and you know turned
things around my heavenly father was
always present and when I went back and
looked through my life as I got a little
bit older
uh there is one presence with me all the
time
that truly got me through all those
times and even though I may not have
known he was there he knew I was there
and he was there all the time and my
faith gives me I mean such tremendous
comfort
and
peace
I always say I want more peace in my
life and what I really mean by that is I
want more
time to have my relationship with God I
have a relationship with God though
which means that it Ebbs and flows
sometimes it's better than others I
actually think questioning and asking
questions about your faith is healthy
because it helps you dig deeper and find
more answers
but my faith has been the center part of
my life I can only conclude that there's
an incredible powerful and loving God
that's helped me reach all these
conclusions
and giving me this journey and if you if
I really step back there's just no way
any of this stuff that's happened I
could have done on my own and the funny
thing about writing a book about how to
be more happy and successful it's a
little bit of a weird feeling because
although I'm giving you all the keys
that I know in the book like all right
I'm 51 what do I know here's like 19 one
more so I go deep as you know on the
mind and habits and time management and
Equanimity and identity and all this
stuff in the book but the truth is that
there are entire pockets of my life
where I can't explain them to you
they're Supernatural like there's entire
times in my life where I'm like all I
can conclude like when the water was
turned off yeah
yeah it's a little bit of a blur and
then I sort of woke up and it was almost
like the Lord just picked me up and
carried me for a while
and then kind of put me back down and
said all right I'm here with you still
but you're gonna you know and he picked
me up for a while and put me back down
again and so it I'd be remiss if I wrote
a book about being happy and successful
and I didn't have a chapter in the book
on the most important central part of
all of it for me which is that this is I
believe God put us here to love one
another God put us here to care about
one another to believe in one another to
show each other how to do better that's
what I think life is and so I also
believe there's a purpose to this life
beyond just being here for 80 or 100
years and our body dies how do I know
that I know that from my dad I know that
from his dad and so my faith is the most
important part of my life I don't have a
life without it that's just the truth
none of this matters without it and the
most powerful thing ever for me is like
those two babies of mine Max and Bella I
love them more than you could possibly
imagine loving two human beings and to
think that the lord loves me even more
than that and loves you even more than
that and loves someone listening to the
man that's powerful and the other last
thing I'll say is I believe in energy I
believe in science I'm one of these
crazy Christian people who believes that
you there's vibrational frequency I
actually believe in all that I just
happen to believe a Creator created all
of that but I don't I'm not a dummy you
and I are great friends because I love
the I love your frequency I love you I
love the energy I feel from you I think
you like mine like we all respond to
energy so I'm a I'm a diverse believer
in that sense I'm just a devout
Christian in the main sense and so I had
to write a book I had to put that in
there do you ever doubt your faith I
have I've questioned it I've doubted it
um sure when you see your father suffer
like that Lord what are we doing here
right or you see a tragedy in life there
are some things that just aren't there
aren't answers to
um but I can tell you that there was a
lot of things about my dad suffering
that served other people including me
and so as I've been able to take away
these keys in my life yeah I think the
truth is that
I don't believe I doubt my faith anymore
to the extent of whether it's true I
doubt my depth of understanding of it I
doubt my depth of sometimes I doubt my I
wish I could become closer
I regret sometimes in life if I'm being
honest that I think a lot of us feel
like I'm going to really get around to
pursuing my faith more aggressively when
right right when and that time never
comes and so as many many years ago I
went no that time is kind of now but
even having said that there are things
about me this calling on my heart that I
feel like I want to get closer I want to
get closer and so the doubt part
probably has changed from doubt to
whether I believe what I believe which I
once have had
to more um
understanding and knowing more than I
know and so that's probably the doubt
part
people listening that maybe they you
know don't have faith in their life but
they actually want to but they just
doubt God exists right and they just
want to maybe take like a step towards
seeing if they can incorporate Faith
whatever that Faith may be by the way
into their life like what do you say to
them well that's a great question and I
get asked that a lot so
um so the first thing I would say to you
is the fact that you're inquiring about
it has been calling on your heart you
would not be you wouldn't have this
calling on your heart unless there was
an existence of something you know you
want to know more about so the fact that
it's a calling no one put that there
that was that was there from your birth
and so you're trying to you're trying to
come home
um and what I would say to do is to get
quiet
and they get still and in Stillness and
quietness there's a lot of answers there
and if there's somebody that you admire
I would say go have a conversation with
them about their belief someone that's
non-judgmental there are great books I
mean depending on the faith you're going
to pursue if you were to pursue my faith
I could certainly recommend some very
specific books that helped me but I
would say that get quiet pray about it
um and then I would say go pursue some
different places see what feels home to
you yeah you know go visit a church go
visit a synagogue if you if that's
appropriate for you and go visit and I
think you'll find your home when you
take action but in life we need to get
in motion and take action to make
something change in our lives and so go
do something about it stop just sitting
there contemplating get quiet get some
answers and then
go try go do something it's so good and
so true and I think what you just said
is really powerful that's my own
experience with going from doubting God
exist for many years to then knowing
beyond a shadow of a doubt he exists but
part of that was going you know to
different churches seeing what actually
felt right because you feel it you feel
it you feel it you can't fake it you
can't fake it you'll feel your home when
you're home and I did too I was raised
in one particular church and then went
to another in another and then I found
what was my home
your challenges don't only make you
stronger they allow you to serve better
I think the default answer for a lot of
people is that your challenges make you
stronger your challenges will you know
to grow muscle you have to break you
have to break your muscle first and all
of these obstacles that I put in your
way allow you to have a a better life
they're making you stronger they're
making you more powerful and that's all
true yes and
the thing that helps me the most is just
tying it back to service because I think
you know humans are built to serve you
are built to serve when you can connect
the challenge that you're going through
as something that's then going to
inspire and help other people
at least for me it always gives me a lot
more strength and a lot more courage to
do the thing that I need to do as
opposed to it just being about me
getting stronger I find a lot of times
me getting stronger is not enough it's
not enough of a reason compared to it's
going to help somebody else as well so
you know that's you hope this video
helps you as well so I think about
when I was doing my tour 2019 and I
broke my neck it was one of the most
challenging times in my life and that
it's already hard enough I'm already you
know on the road report of the year on
the road 90 straight days me Nina my
camera mandani and there were a lot of
challenges in making that whole tour
happen and new city every four days and
all of the stuff that goes into you know
it was my first ever tour and then I
broke my neck two-thirds of the way
through
so as if things weren't hard enough now
I break my neck I can't drive anymore uh
I'm in insane amounts of pain I have a
concussion uh and I'm still making
videos I I struggled with the decision
this is a real decision do I do I quit
the tour or not do I quit the tour do I
go home
there's still another month on the road
it's not just me it's also Nina who has
to do a lot more work now she's got to
drive this giant Suburban across the
country uh Danny the camera guy has to
do a lot more work you know it's a lot
of stress I'm basically out of
commission and all I could do was talk
which is great for speaking but sucks
for everything else so what do we do
the thing that made me want to at least
try to keep going I didn't know that I
would go for another month but I thought
let's just do the next city let's just
do the next city let's go to Kansas City
Kansas City was the next stop
let's go to Kansas City and see what
happens
what got me through it was
thinking about somebody in the audience
thinking about one of you guys who is
struggling with something physically up
until that point I dealt with a lot of
mental issues mental issues mindset
issues
things like believe in you not good
enough lack of self-worth you don't have
a message to share imposter syndrome all
of those things right even here we're
filming we're about to go through a car
wash
uh we're we're next so we're probably
gonna get some crazy noise we have to
talk loud I used to
be so worried about that stuff that I
wouldn't I wouldn't feel like oh I can't
film going to a car wash you know the
noise whatever now I look at it as
opportunities like let's go like that's
not a good enough reason maybe the video
quality sucks I you know I hope not
um maybe you can't hear me loud enough I
hope not but but not letting those
things get in your way because that
stuff happens all the time you know like
that stuff happens all the time look
we're not
[Music]
we're in the car wash we're next
depending on how long that guy ahead of
us takes you might you might see it in
this video I dealt with a lot of those
mindset issues those lack of belief
issues those worthiness issues and I I
battled them and I've been through them
and
yeah have a few lessons to share
and over the years of me trialing and
failing and you know 20 plus years of
doing this
my hope is to make the path a little bit
easier for you so that you don't have to
struggle as much as I did the path can
be a little bit sooner a little bit
faster a little bit less painful right
but I'd never been through anything
really physical you know I've broken my
toe
I remember breaking my toe
uh and then going for a run
and I was doing Instagram live at the
times like a light run fast Jog and I
like my toe was hurting so much and I
just kept powering through I didn't
later realize I broke my toe but that's
not really anything major right you know
if somebody's going through something
physical and major it's like you broke
your toe come on it's not a big deal and
so I never felt like I could
serve or push people who
had a physical limitation
I had a physical kind of injury because
I'd never gone through it and I don't
feel right pushing people on things that
I haven't experienced in some form
myself right
so here I am 2009 2019 now I break my
neck now I might have a concussion I
mean more pain I've ever been in my life
concussion if you haven't been through
it is just devastating because it's not
just the physical pain of not being able
to move your body and you know neck and
potential having spinal surgery which is
crazy scary but also not being able to
think clearly first for me I I value
that a lot like I love thinking you know
I love problem solving and not being
able to think clearly and just be a
vegetable on the couch all day was it
was
devastating so getting through that and
then deciding I'm gonna I'm gonna keep
going
I'm gonna at least try for the next stop
in Kansas City why
because if I can get through this
yes it's a challenge that will teach me
and make me stronger and I have a lesson
that I can learn from it but
if I can get through this then hopefully
can serve as an inspiration for other
people who are going through something
physical as well but it's not just a
mindset issue but they have physical
limitations
you know the first couple the first
night in the hospital I was a you know a
train wreck then I came home and uh to
our Airbnb they let me out of the
hospital and I remember two specific
Moments One trying to get into the car
so we're at the hospital I get
discharged I'm excited to go home fresh
air oh my gosh it's amazing and I have
this neck brace on I can't move I have
very low flexibility and I'm now the
passenger I'm not allowed to drive
because I can't turn my head so Nina has
to Nina has to drive and I'm in the
parking lot of the hospital
and
I'm trying to get into the passenger
side I'm in the passenger seat right now
in my car I'm trying to get into the
passenger side of the car and I can't
and it hurts too much and I get to the
point where I have one foot in the car
and one foot out of the car
and it's a Suburban so this is giant
step up to get in
and I remember being so
I was in so much pain
that I couldn't go forward into the car
I didn't have the strength and every
time I lift it off it killed everything
in my body the whole like all my back up
into my neck everything was in massive
pain but I also couldn't get back down
because that was hurting too much too so
I was in I was stuck in this limbo if I
can't go forward I can't go back
[Music]
Nina's trying to you know push me up to
get me in and then I remember just
crying
I'm in the parking lot of that oh we're
going in the car wash I'm in the parking
lot I'm gonna have to talk louder I'm in
the parking lot
of the hospital and I'm crying
out of frustration and I can't remember
the last time I was that frustrated that
I just broke down and cried and I I
didn't know what to do next everything
hurt I can't move forward I can't move
backwards I'm just overwhelmed by pain
and frustration and I'm crying in the
parking lot of the hospital
eventually Nina
just pushes me in
one hand on each butt cheek and like in
you go and I got it and it hurt but but
then I was in
and that was just
an overwhelming moment
and then I remember that night
here we go car wash
that night
uh it was I mean I can't sleep it's
terrible i've got you know neck brace on
I'm not used to sleeping with it I'm in
massive pain and it's it's three in the
morning
and I have to go to the bathroom
and so I'm sitting I I can get myself to
sit up they taught me in the hospital
how to push yourself from
um
lying down to
to setting up oh look here comes look at
the foam look at that guys how to go
from lying down to sitting up without
hurting yourself too much like
minimizing the pain as much as possible
so they taught me how to do that
so three in the morning I have to go to
the bathroom I get up uh I push myself
into the seating position
I'm starting to feel dizzy I have a
concussion right I'm starting to feel
dizzy I can't see anything because it's
really dark and
I'm worried that if I stand up I might
fall over
how I got the concussion was I fainted I
fainted my head on the wall and then
cracked my my the back of my neck open
I'm worried that if I stand up I might
faint and I might fall over again
and I Nina's asleep next to me
look at this
were you sleeping on the floor Linda's
joining in no you're on the bed
on the floor
she was afraid she's gonna wake me up I
mean bless Nina's Hearts I mean she had
no sleep during this whole time too
right so she's asleep it's three in the
morning and I and I
I don't want to wake her up
one because I feel bad for her because
she hasn't slept at all but also feel I
feel helpless I feel so helpless
that I mean all this pain and I can't
even go I can't even go to the bathroom
by myself like I need help to go to the
bathroom I felt so helpless and I said
it's it's not worth it for me to get up
and and potentially like if I fall
that's that's no bueno right I'm back to
the hospital probably if I fault so I
wake up Nina and I mean it may not seem
like a big deal but it it felt like a
big deal like I felt just helpless
and so I had yeah I woke her up she
helped me go to the bathroom and you
know I did my business and went back to
sleep but
those two moments in particular were the
most painful moments of that whole
experience
it's the best uh
and and the thing that got me through it
the thing that gave me the motivation
was that
hopefully somebody else who's going
through some kind of painful moment
right now
we'll be able to resonate with this and
be inspired by this whether it's
actually true or not it was a story that
I was telling myself I told myself
somebody's going to be inspired by this
and I still made videos and my next
round of videos I couldn't do the whole
thing so Nina did some of it I did some
of it
um and I'm sitting there I'm I'm now
overweight because I'm uh you know I
haven't been able to work out
um I haven't been eaten as clean as I
was normally I got a giant scab if you
look at some of those old videos I have
this huge scab on my forehead again
normally like oh my gosh I got this
giant scab on my you might be worried
about a little pimple look at this giant
scab coming down my forehead it looked
like Harry Potter the thing that gets me
through it is
other people
who have some kind of issue like to
having a bad hair day or a pimple on
their face might be inspired by this to
go and take action what Nina has a
paintball whatever you want to show
everybody your pimple on your forehead
again whether it's true or not it was a
story that I was telling myself that
somebody else is going to be inspired by
this and it's going to allow them to go
and do their thing
um now fast forward
make the videos we release the videos a
lot of people were inspired by a lot of
people did message me DM me email me
tell me in future interviews you know I
was I was telling myself I couldn't do
this because of X because I had a
headache
and here you are doing your videos with
a concussion
giant Scout on your face neck brace in
massive pain breaking your neck and I
told myself what I have no excuse I'm
gonna go do my thing because Evan did
his thing
but again whether it was true or not
the thing that got me to get through the
challenge in a way that I'm proud of
myself for
was the connection to service
that it's not just here to make me
stronger which it did made me incredibly
like I can't believe I did that that guy
is still in me that I could go and do
that again hopefully they'll break my
neck again but I could do that
It Made Me Stronger but even more
valuable
is me feeling like this is gonna mean
something to somebody else so whatever
challenge you're going through
understand that yes you know your
purpose comes from your pain
this will make you a better person
but the thing that will help you get
through it at least in my experience is
connecting to somebody else
that there are tons of people out there
who are also struggling with the same
thing that you are struggling with right
now and when you get through it your
story will be an inspiration for them
your journey through it
will motivate them to have the courage
to show up for their lives as well and
when you can actually connect it to
service I think everything is better you
are built to serve we made it through
the car wash
[Laughter]
good job Nina hopefully that uh you
heard all that stuff and it was valuable
and life-changing and if not I love you
anyway some of you done so much work to
get out there to finally catch the wave
anybody ever caught a wave in business
or a wave in the ocean for that matter
you catch a wave in the ocean you know
what that's like a perfect wave or a
good wave all of you probably done at
least a little one and it's almost
inexpressible isn't it it's an
incredible feeling you're kind of
connected to God and the ocean and
yourself in those moments and it's just
a wonderful journey and these waves can
take you places you would ever otherwise
never get without them and you can get
there faster also true in business you
gotta paddle and kick and scratch and
Claw and move and you're using things
you've never used before you're you're
finding assets you have but you didn't
even know you had to get out there then
you catch these waves in business and
it's wonderful and it can take you
places and it feels a certain way it's
never felt before and many of you caught
waves I'm sure you've caught a wave in
business in the past or multiple ways
some of you probably even got some
pretty darn big ones well let me ask you
a question
that's when I got out there I started to
say to myself well you know heck I've
caught three or four of these waves this
is pretty darn good I could probably
float and I'll probably just keep
catching them if I float but would I
well you know I would what would happen
if I stopped completely moving my arms
and legs and kicking and paddling
I'd sink and if I'm not careful if I
don't do it long enough I could drown
and I see that happen all the time in
business see in my business the paddling
and the kicking and the swimming is
recruiting and developing people
leadership sales skills running a system
in a particular way those are the things
that are the paddling and the kicking
and prospecting in my business in your
business it may be something different
but nonetheless I'm not immune to the
laws of nature if I sit in that ocean
and I stop moving I stop paddling and
kicking and doing what you got to do I
won't float I'll sink I'm not immune to
the laws of the ocean nature the
universe gravity you name it and neither
are you I'm also not immune and nor are
you to the laws of business The Laws of
Success The Laws of Success say if you
stop doing those things you don't float
you never grow or you never just stay
the same in business you're either
growing you're dying you're either
sinking or swimming I want you to be
swimming I want you to be riding Waves
by the way the bigger the waves the
harder you got to work to go catch them
but what most people do in business is
to fall in love with a delusion or the
illusion of the fact that I can stop at
some point I've seen people stop quickly
in my business a couple weeks into the
business either get an award for
bringing the most people to the meeting
oh I can stop kicking and paddling now I
can stop calling people and seeing
people and I see them sink I've seen
people a year or two later get a
promotion to a certain level and they go
oh now I can stop paddling and kicking
and I'm going to float and keep riding
these waves and I've seen them sink and
sometimes I've seen them drowned
and that's a sad thing to see someone
drown and go out of business just simply
because they fell in love with the
illusion and the lie that they could
float and stop moving I've seen it
happen five years in 15 years in 20
years in a million a year two million a
year you name it I've seen it when
they've developed a bunch of people when
they have it you'd say well yeah that's
not true I mean not everybody sinks I
mean I have friends heck in my own
business dude they've stopped paddling
kicking and they still ride a wave or
two here and there and they're pretty
happy
really are they really happy will they
ever know what it would have been like
to write the biggest and best waves of
their life the answer is no if you stop
paddling kicking you'll never know where
you could have gone
more importantly you'll never know who
you could have become see the people who
paddle and kick forever and make that
decision they've got a chance to become
the highest version of themselves the
highest expression of themselves which I
think is what life's about see the
champions in Fitness in faith in the
water in every area of Life make a
decision early that they are about the
paddling and kicking because that's the
ticket to the biggest the next and the
biggest waves of life life isn't about
catching a few and stopping life's about
the next wave ask any Surfer they're
chasing the next big wave they're
chasing the great one and once they
catch that they want to chase another
one because it's about being out there
it's about being in the game it's about
riding the big waves it's about finding
the highest version and expression of
you and I want to challenge you to do
that in your business I want to
challenge you to see the great ones
decide see the average they they look
for reasons they look for reasons to
stop paddling kicking oh now I can oh
now I can see the Champions don't want
those reasons the Champions want to keep
paddling and kicking to ride the big one
The Great Wave of their life
and I think you'd agree with me that
life can only get better if you'll keep
paddling and kicking please don't stop
please don't fall in love with that lie
and know the truth that the winning way
is the way to keep paddling and kicking
you're not about floating you're not
about sinking you're not about drowning
you're about riding the biggest waves of
your life in the future and whatever
area matters to you whether it's your
faith or your family or your Fitness or
your business make the decision that
you're going to do the things that's
required to ride the next big wave and
it will take you places you can't even
imagine the Dallas Uber driver oh so as
somebody who has gotten into countless
Ubers and some small percentage of them
know who I am and then of course they
start asking questions
talk to me about chasing your dreams and
this quote that you have that an aha
moment does not necessarily lead to an
aha life
yeah the Uber driver in Dallas that's in
this book
um I get choked up when I think about
him uh an aha I choked up I get choked
up because
what happens for me every single day
is and you hear from people every single
day you've got millions and millions of
people that are inspired by empowered by
impacted by your content there are
people out there that use your work as a
lifeline
and it is humbling
and what I am
really present to in the work that I'm
putting out and the stuff that I'm
sharing whether it's my failures or the
things that I'm using that are helping
me in my own struggles
is just how much people are holding
themselves back
and how much pain people feel
because most folks know what they dream
about
and what they want
and yet
they're spending all of their time and
energy arguing against what they want
and so you can have all these epiphanies
I hope that when somebody listens to our
conversation and watches this that they
have a massive aha moment but it's not
going to mean
if you don't take action and do
something about it
the aha moment is the door that opens
but your new life does not begin unless
you step through the door
and most people and that's what was
so kind of
you know the simple idea of high-fiving
yourself of encouraging yourself of
supporting yourself most people when you
have an aha moment and the door to your
new life opens up
instead of going I got this let's go and
high-fiving yourself to step forward
most of us go I don't know if I'm worth
it I don't know if right now is the
right time to do this I don't think I'm
good enough I failed so many times I
can't go through that door
and that's the problem I want to attack
right now that there is somewhere in
your life that you know what you want
you can feel it pulling you and you are
actively arguing against it you're
bringing yourself down you're beating
yourself out like people will cheer for
you and me they won't cheer for
themselves
I'm the same way and so this Uber driver
the story that you're talking about I
get into the car and we start driving
and I'm on the phone as we're driving
and I'm having a conversation with
somebody about this daytime talk show
that I launched which was a dream with
Sony Pictures Television and then uh was
promptly fired after season one it was a
huge failure because we didn't make it
to season two
huge failure in real world terms massive
success when it comes to the timeline of
my life and so I'm talking to this
person about the talk show I hang up the
phone and this Uber driver comes alive
he's like oh my gosh I can't believe
you're in my cab and I'm like why and he
says because I I want to talk to you
about something I think you can help me
and I'm like great how can I help you
and he says I have a dream of being a
oscar-winning
actor and creating opportunities for
other black and Latino men to do the
same in acting and I'm like freaking
fantastic what the [ __ ] are you doing in
Dallas right yeah the guy's 25 and so I
I go you know the game is in New York
and L.A I mean sure you can act you can
write stuff you can be here in Dallas
but why are you not in La why are you
not in New York and he's like you're
right you're right you're right I need
to move to LA like why not
and he says I have 700 in my bank
account I'm like that's freaking
fantastic you have 700 in a car dude
drop me off and get driving what are you
waiting for and so we have this whole
conversation and I write about it in
this book where I am actively arguing
for his dream and he is actively arguing
against his dream
and what is so sad is throughout this
conversation Tom he's like you're right
700 could get me there you're right I am
only 25. you're right if I keep thinking
and thinking and thinking and thinking
about what I want to be doing I'm not
only going to drive in circles my whole
life is going to spin in circles as I
think about what I want and I don't do
[ __ ] about it and then you are going to
find yourself not at 25 but at 45 or 65
and you're going to be so filled with
regret that you never put a put a bet on
yourself
and so this conversation ends with him
declaring that he's going to go to
California and me giving him a bunch of
tools that I talk about in this book and
the point of the story is does he move
or not I don't know
the point of the story is it's so easy
to see what somebody else should do it's
so easy to cheer for somebody else we
all do that right we cheer for our
favorite sports teams we follow our
favorite influencers and authors we plan
birthday parties for our friends we take
on extra work from our colleagues we
support everyone around us we do not
know how to do it for ourselves
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you're
ready to raise your standards check the
video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there in an emergency you
tap all the body's resources for some
threat whether it's real or imagined and
so then when you're releasing all of
these chemicals we are literally drawing
the body's life force and turning it
into chemistry